hello welcome back to new rockstars
debrief I'm Erik Bosse and joining me
today are sam basher oh hello Maude
Garrett that's me and Phillip Melina I
forgot what I sound like the Fab Four is
back this is excited today we're talking
about the Avengers in-game movie and the
new events of fallen cast photos and
what they tell us about the cast of this
movie and a clue spotted in an endgame
featurette that came out also the Game
of Thrones finale and how will diverge
from George RR Martin's books we're also
talking about Zack Snyder's defense of
Batman's right to kill and we look at
the Eternals which will be a part of MCU
phase 4 we got some news about that this
week also some other news cool yeah if
you listen to this right now as a
podcast you might notice today we got
brand new cover or a real fancy little
design there I did it so I appreciate
the compliment they send me on Twitter
that change is actually to coordinate
with our even bigger announcement today
Westeros weekly is coming back starting
Monday this time it's also gonna
surprise you can subscribe right now on
Apple podcast or the Himalaya app where
you can actually submit questions to us
so that we can answer them on the show
or subscribe anywhere you listen to
podcast were actually gonna get into
more detail about our Game of Thrones
podcast coverage something really
excited about it we'll do it later when
we talk about Game of Thrones yeah let's
get started with our lead story oh yeah
what you hear we are one month out from
Avengers endgame and Marvel has released
32 posters each one features a different
of interest character now half the
posters are in full color and they show
survivors of Thanos to snap the living
the people who are still alive at the
end of infinity war but the other half
are in black and white and they show the
dead and or dusted each poster has the
phrase avenge the Fallen written over
the characters face now these posters
confirm some big news for us first that
Wong and Valkyrie are among the
survivors of the snap and they're gonna
be part of this story we figured they
were because we didn't see him die but
another character we didn't see died who
is among the black and white ones is
Shuri sister to Black Panther T'Challa
she's in black and white meaning she
must have dusted or died somewhere off
screen who and in the
Chinese version of the new endgame
poster you can actually see her standing
among the fallen characters so that's
double confirmation and now I made a
whole other video about Sheree so go
check that out if you haven't already
different ways that she could have died
did we actually see her death in
infinity war but it didn't look like her
death at the time or are there other
reasons why they may be saving that
footage is it something we're gonna see
an end game but here's the larger
question be answered and that's who is
in this movie well here's the deal
everyone will obviously show up in this
movie in some way right whether they get
resurrected maybe we flashback to them
when they were still alive but the
question of who is alive and who will be
actively participating in the plan for
the book this move who's gonna be
driving the story now obviously all the
og Avengers the original six are there
plus he got McCoy a joining them and
rocket captain Marvel's joined in the
mix apparently Valkyrie mbaku is still
alive Wong is still alive happy Hogan
Pepper Potts not sure he though
that's a machoke but who else now a lot
of you guys have been sending me
screenshots of IMDB Phillip mentioned a
second ago and you send these people
email or tweet them at me yeah news
about ty simpkins that was a kid from
Ironman threes in Jurassic world as well
but he played Harley the boy who bonds
with Tony Stark in that movie also
Catherine Langford has been rumored to
be part of this story and someone went
on IMDB I guess one of the actors or
extras on the movie credited themselves
an IMDB as seventy scientist and all of
you guys have been tweeting that out
saying oh is that is that proof of
time-travel does it mean the Avengers so
then go back to the 1970s
maybe meet with Howard Stark who was
active during that time does this mean
that Tony could have a flashback using
his barf technology to when he was a boy
with his father like he did in civil war
or is it just wrong
because here's something that you guys
all just need to keep in mind IMDB for a
movie that has not come out yet is not
confirmed it is as of right now still
inaccurate in a lot of ways it's
crowd-sourced media its Wikipedia people
can it's even less edited and less
monitored than Wikipedia is which if you
try to change something on Wikipedia
like when Philip change to the page of
Moon face to have my face on it
they get on that right away you can't
know that thing lasted like a year
anybody can change that stuff and the
reason why they donated it is the
editors at IMDB don't know anymore than
people who are part of the movie or
actors who are on the set for a day who
is and who is in that movie what
character they were playing so they
don't they don't change it yet so that's
why you can go on I'm Beauty and c-type
Simpkins and and that stuff actors will
just put that in there themselves and
I'm BB was one who broke through the
news that ty simpkins was gonna be in it
so it's not confirmed but it's not not
confirmed either it's just we don't know
anyway even with these possible
additions the question I'm curious to
know from you guys there's about half as
many characters in of interest in game
as there were enough interest infinity
war courtesy of Thanos thanks bud now do
we think that this will make this a
better movie having a smaller more
condensed cast at least when it comes to
screen have been using their imagination
to picture this handsome devil did a
nose do a good job for the movie by
making less people will be better off
especially since the ruses have said
they're more of an ensemble group and
having so many people in the first movie
force them to make it Bannos the story
and scatter the rest and keep in mind I
mean it would they actually did the
smartest thing that I could have ever
imagined honestly Civil War could have
benefited from this they made a nose the
protagonist of infinity war so that they
could focus on him and if you think
about any either not just feature film
but any epic story just in from even
Greek mythology you follow one person
their hero they have their goal and they
go through change and they meet people
on the way well danos he has his goal we
deals with people on the way but he's
the one has a fully realized arc they
nailed it with that so they can do it
with more people now it's the fact that
okay so Thanos is gonna go inside let's
make a whole group the star again and
yeah they do got a pair down yeah as it
may be a comparison to the other Russo
movies that they've made their wish over
other movies like with Captain America
Winter Soldier that's cap story you get
to learn about Winter Soldier you get to
learn what his place is in a modern
society and how things have changed and
how his perspective on politics and
himself in how he fits into everything
it changes but in the second movie
you're able to see that like they could
take like Iron Man somebody who's had
nineteen thousand movies that he's been
the star of and now you can kind of turn
him and allow him be an antagonist so in
in a way with infinity war and end game
you now set up Thanos to give him a full
movie and you allowed him to kind of
take a backseat when it comes to the
sequel of endgame and allow the heroes
to kind of take more of a center stage
and just go up against them because you
know what Thanos is ho deal is now you
don't have to you don't have to
establish him is what I'm trying to say
like they did in Winter Soldier yeah you
have to establish sentence cuz he's the
new player here and we've had so many
other movies we understand who these
characters are and now they get to have
their hero moment I totally agree with
you at the same time I think there's a
reason why this movie is over three
hours long now there's a lot of good
buys or doing justice to these
characters obviously some of these
heroes need a little bit more screen
time but it has to be kind of like
evenly delivered throughout them all and
there's a lot there yeah I also think
that even even for three hours I think
they still won't go very much into
anybody who's
like even let's say midpoint everybody
comes back or something I still I don't
think that's gonna happen I think
they're gonna focus on the people that
are left behind because that's the more
interesting story right that's the Left
Behind series that's the left overs
that's what do you do in that world
that's devastated versus like hey where
you guys been like we don't really need
to catch up on nothing right I agree
three hours do we think that's too much
story they never think they've earned it
after 22 hours not ask excuse me triple
that oh my god that they've earned yeah
but it's also good walking out in the
middle of each no you know they earn it
but man boy howdy that's they're trying
us they better better wind the next
movie with spider-man how far from home
is one hour there you go wanted on two
VHS tapes the as long as they fell all
that I mean the Lord of the Rings how it
was a huge ensemble move each of those
chapters were and they feel like they
felt it they felt it and they filled it
and I was satisfied they filmed it all
80 of those Indians for Return of the
King
oh my goodness oh that's that's a better
example in my head I did in high school
I did choir and at the light and the
senior show you do do a big goodbye so
everyone comes down does their like
heart felt like this is why I love this
program and you're like oh my god this
show should have been an hour and a half
it is now 10:00 p.m. on a school night I
want to go home yeah don't need Hank Pym
to get a real heartfelt like no okay
good to have you back there now I want
to ask you guys do you think there's any
significance to the direction that the
actors are facing in the pictures now if
you're listening to this on podcast go
check out online the different
directions of each of these posters most
of them of the living characters we're
talking about are facing the same way
but some of them are looking in the
opposite direction all the black and
white ones are looking in the same
direction the living ones we have Ant
Man Bruce Banner Okoye and Captain
Marvel are all looking to the right I
mean it's it's obvious right the so if
they're the left is like are normal
people the right you're a scroll
I don't know it'll look or they assign
you a different photo editor and they
didn't horizontally that's unlikely that
that would be a fun clue for our school
search serious lender and non moon-like
all these faces are you just check out
lookup database horribly thin face
someone on reddit i believe made all
these into like a flipbook photo sam you
were telling about how like shout out to
panda underscore hat yeah maybe we can
put a link to that or something Michelle
yeah it looks really cool and then the
middle one is Gamora looking right down
the barrel of the lens of the camera so
is there a reason why she's looking into
or why Gamora but they're looking
towards something the imminent threat
yeah I do kind of think that right it's
like they're it's it's a complete full
vision like they're the full feel
decision yeah the field of vision and a
vision is that like a baseball field
where visions come back to play with the
family yeah the farm I'm sorry too young
to get that reference probably why you
ain't seen because being red is the most
recognizable thing about them but mod
you have another question for us oh yes
it's a trivia question oh no he's right
it's who's the least wrong please
distribute the cards accordingly with
your shop hey we go on here early in
though
[Music]
a little late sound cute pretty ominous
goodness me early in their career this
MCU star played a minor role in the
popular crime drama series chips okay
all of our answers are in the bucket
behind us I wasn't on screen when I
pointed forward at the end of the
episode and leave your answers in the
comments below don't don't research it
just I'll get it right but they're
pretty good a bunch of Boy Scouts but
first we want to take a minute to talk
about one of our sponsors of this
episode better help is there something
that interferes with your happiness or
is preventing you from achieving your
goals if so better help online
counseling is there for you better help
offers licensed professional counselors
who are specialized in issues such as
depression stress anxiety relationships
family conflicts LGBT matters greed
self-esteem and more and anything that
you might have heard about better help
just to know that they've done a really
good job like listening to feedback and
making necessary changes so you can
connect with your professional counselor
in safe and private online environments
anything that you share is of course
confidential and it's very very
convenient you can get help at your own
time and at your own pace you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
plus chat and text with your therapist
and if you're not happy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
any time at no additional charge but
best of all its truly affordable and
debrief listeners get 10% off your first
month with discount code rockstars and
something to keep in mind this is not a
crisis line this is proactive mental
health so if you are in a moment of
crisis there are other resources to go
through for that but this is a good way
to get a step ahead of ever getting to
that point so why not get started today
just go to better help calm slash
rockstars simply fill out a
questionnaire and get matched with a
counselor that you'll love better help
calm slash rock stars
yeah therapy yeah therapy now Sam
there's some other news that came up
this week what did you yes this week we
found out that Angelina Jolie the Peter
Soph is in talks to star an upcoming MCU
Eternals movie we've heard about in this
one from a little but it's going to be
written by Matthew and Ryan Firpo who
wrote a popular blacklist script called
ruin and directed by Chloe
Zhou who comes from the indie film world
the Eternals look like people look like
humans and they are very powerful and
basically live for
it's very this is one of the most
convoluted characters I've ever read
about in Marvel Comics but they're
coming to the big screen yes and their
stories are limited though they were
created by cosmic beings called the
Celestials you know star Lords that ego
the Living Planet who was that was
established and we found out he was a
celestial in the MCU in darkness - now
the Eternals are mostly good guys for
the most part and the Celestials also
created the deviants who are there
they're ugly guys they're mostly bad
guys - and Thanos is an eternal fun fact
but he has a few deviant genes in him so
that's a mix of both that's where he
gets his more persuasive violent
tendencies oh yeah
so basically in the comics the
Celestials came to earth and they
created modern-day humans as well as
deviants and that actually sometimes led
to mutants depending on what you're
reading and Eternals are the perfect man
and that led to many controversies in
the comics but you can go and do that
research for yourself a collection yeah
big man it's a complicated thing to
state but I will say they are on this
panel right now we don't know much about
the plot of this movie but rumors are
saying that it will be a love story or
at least it involve a love story between
two eternals named Icarus and Cersei now
how do we think these characters will
fit in with the Avengers there's so much
more powerful especially that someone
like Black Widow and Rhodey being on the
team seeing characters like this that
are literally perfect they might not be
able to stack up so if we have a
Eternals do we even need the Avengers
the answer is yes here's a quick one but
I do want to hear your points of view
it's just these these characters aren't
that well-known the Icarus is that I can
see the inspiration when it comes from
Greek mythology but overall they are not
that well-known I hope that they lead
into because in the comic sometimes they
lived on earth and I kind of hope that's
just like no the Celestials just made
them on Titan and Titan is a different
plane and they live there but now
they're gonna there are some maybe
survivors out there and they're gonna
come to earth and that's how our
character well maybe you're asking like
in terms of like scale like if you have
characters that are essentially gods
which we've seen and like the tcu and
the DC Comics a lot of these characters
are essentially gods we have the new
gods in the DC Comics which Jack Kirby
created before going to Marvel to create
basically the equivalent in the Marvel
world yes thank you hats
very good yeah and didn't neil gaiman he
said they write a volume of Eternals
yeah yeah so if you have like these
characters who are like perfect godly
beings does that is it less interesting
to see a character who can has
omnipotence as opposed to characters are
a bit more grounded like Black Widow and
Rohde in yeah say it say it
yeah I mean for that part of the
question you just asked yeah they need
each other right like you can't you
can't have power without weakness right
you can't have like you need to see that
parent in fact I think that parent is
very interesting to see together right
the the storylines of you know a single
person I mean just have the the image of
for some reason you know the end of
eternals 3 and you see all the Eternals
lined up and for some reason you know
they they are unable to achieve
something and little Rhodey just
dragging his chewed off and so like he's
the one that can like actually achieve
it and save the day at the end that
matters so much more because something
that a man can do that a god can't is
actually more impressive than a God
doing it
sure thank you I feel like we've sort of
seen something like this before I mean
the concept really is having gods that
don't understand earth or like the ins
and outs or the daily occurrences of
earth trying to adapt and learn for the
first time but that was thought it makes
sense why you want to ask this question
because if the Eternals show up it's
like maybe the Avengers could finally
take a vacation it's not just Hawkeye
gone to the beach with his kids but like
but at the same time now you bring up
the best point where it's like an
Avengers 2 they do a really good I think
they do an okay job showing why Hawkeye
is important on the team where it's like
you do need that kind of like person
who's willing to put everything on the
dad you need a daddy dad because it's
also like maybe Thor if he got his stuff
together he could be like the ultimate
Avenger and just kind of saved the earth
by himself any fool can be a Hawkeye
real man no daddy there's a hot guy
you are not enough anybody can I am
interested to see how they expanded the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because with
Captain Marvel they introduced us more
to the cream and they showed us some
more cosmic side this could be a more
like godlike and maybe magical there's a
couple of different elements that you
can dive into and also the scale of this
will be a lot bigger so it would be
interesting I do have a question now if
we do take it out from Earth and we go
in to say that you know Titans and we go
out into the celestial void is that do
you become less interested in that I do
yeah like when when vision came into the
scene I remember thinking like he's too
much of a God he's not captivating or
interesting and I'm sorry vision heads
I've never been interested in the MCU
version of vision as much as I thought
Paul Bettany I think I felt this way in
the third act - Captain Marvel - when
characters are too powered up the only
way I think introducing cosmic things is
interesting to see in a movie for me is
if they have like a sense of humor about
it the way they did in the galaxy movies
and mod brought up earlier American Gods
which is such an interesting idea is
that God being depleted of their
immortality but also just being forced
to interact in such a mortal level like
that becomes much more interesting yeah
oh yeah because I could only they were
losing power because no one was
worshiping gods anymore because everyone
was becoming non-believers and so unless
you're worshiping them they lost power I
think or else you would a new godlike
technology I think that's it you're
threatened also there's an idea of like
maybe there's a new generation of
Eternals and like unlike the American
gods new gods but these are like we need
this person to be able to keep the
eternal line going because right now
they seem pretty decimated in the MCU
because Thanos maybe killed them he also
said that they may have one gone extinct
but I think maybe Thanos him a little
nudge that direction so hey it's it's
gonna be interesting but we got some
more news for you Phillip yes oh yeah
you guys want to know you're telling us
about this feature at that came yeah
earlier when you guys walked in waiting
footage but actually we like what's your
law and we did discover something in
there so okay so it's an interesting
Avengers tidbit Marvel released his
featurette called we lost which I like
that they're you know just admitting
that finally it features Kevin Feige and
some of the stars of endgame just
reflecting on the big
loss that the characters experience at
the end of infinity war it doesn't show
new footage but we did notice that when
Robert Downey jr. is speaking he seems
to be sitting on the set of shuri's lab
in Wakanda now it's possible that this
was shot a very long time ago like
during infinity war and you know that's
not as big a deal but it's also very
possible that he's shooting endgame and
he happens to be at the lab in Wakanda
which is very interesting because why
why would it be a sure he's lab okay so
if you remember Eric did a video
actually a while back
that's vision still alive right
confirmed theories all right we also
throw out some theories just in general
about shuri's work with vision during
infinity war we don't really see exactly
what she does during it but she's you
know this brilliant like techno
scientist she could have maybe uploaded
his consciousness somewhere and possibly
saved him that way because you can
download vision for sure but also this
saves us Jarvis kind of in you strike it
with lightning or something there also
is the concept maybe she put like a
tracker or some sort of a way to track
the mind stone oh yeah which day knows
now has to be a way to potentially find
a knows but and then you know obviously
we found out earlier that she passed
away of our IP lovely baby but if that
happened then she wasn't able to tell
anyone that she did that um kind of
reminds me of mists calendar and Buffy
she knows the secret to getting an angel
soul back and then he kills her so what
do you guys think why might I earn man
be there do you think it's for one of
the reasons I said or am i overthinking
it is he in costume there or is that
just what are you dresses like these
days those glasses in the movie I feel
like or a version of those glasses at
least wearing makeup always got I mean
this is all my life every day I come
Tony Stark
I like the idea of it being vision
because visions great and I didn't know
it Philip I think he'd had a sort of
small stroke in the middle of that
statement when he said vision was an
interesting character I'll just mad now
the idea of him being like an AI within
the system that could be used get him
back to his Jarvis days and kind of
helping the team either build like their
New Avengers armor maybe they know
something maybe they'll help heal
helped them navigate through the time
vortex is to go back in time and bring
him back
being like if you guys are familiar with
sliders bringing them back to you know
the current universe there's a lot of
different ways you can go about it but
again vision great character putting
that out there glad we all agree yeah
put it out there we don't all look great
we don't I
it's it's hard when it comes to like can
they reboot vision is that possible
because vision one of the ingredients
for him is the mind stone if the mind
stones gone or destroyed he like where's
vision soul is that inside the computer
or is it inside the myself where's the
human soul is it in the chest or the
head position do anybody like Alaska I
lost mine if you find my soul please I I
think if anything one of the theories I
had in that video you talked about is
that vision could still be in the mind
stone because that seemed to be like the
most important piece to his identity
there's it contains an AI yeah I mean I
mean if we're complicating that but
essentially if is that his brain because
if so like our consciousness is in our
brain his brain is just data isn't it I
think that was well they were trying to
extract in a way that vision could still
be vision without the mind stone stuck
up there yeah I I do like this idea of
she you know when she was swiping away
different neural connections to the mind
stone on her hollow projection board
making references of things that you
definitely only get if you saw them or
having a soul it's a boy yeah I think it
might be interesting if she's able if
they find some kind of like hidden
message somewhere in her computer and
that leads them to the next step
whether it's figuring out how the
Infinity stones work how to build
quantum Armour or how to bring down
Thanos or where the
are ya maybe a man isn't sure he's left
because he's realized oh my god
you had all of this intelligence and I
wasn't privy to it supercharge myself
Jack saw her second I really want a
Gundam sighs Iron Man suit just one time
in this movie right right I'm gonna made
out of vibranium so it's just like Oh
awesome mod was telling me about Game of
Thrones stuff and I wanted to tell you
guys about it I'm wearing this dress
because I am motor of Dragons Mountains
actually commented on Game of Thrones
recently noting that the end of his book
series is gonna be completely different
to this finale
they have wished they've gone different
roads Ones and taken the Kings Road the
other one hasn't taken the road yet
because he hasn't her to know about us
we're gonna do something a little bit
different and speculate about the books
now consider this your spoiler warning
for the book series if you haven't read
them you're not going to read them don't
wanna know about it so assuming george
RR martin finishes the last two books
there's a there's an old alternate
universe version of Westeros a universe
so if you don't know the books Catelyn
Stark is resurrected as Lady Stoneheart
like what said beric Dondarrion has done
so she doesn't actually die die even
though she's dead
and then yeah Ollie he's not even in the
books that never happened there was a
bunch of other stuff yeah there's
another potential like Targaryen that
could have to try to take back the Iron
Throne by marrying Elia Martell son to
Daenerys that is in the works we don't
know if Jon Snow comes back because
that's a cliff well it wasn't Sansa at
Winterfell it was married to stuff
actually we're talking about Jon Snow
because you know he's I feel like they
kind of combined characters put them
together
Jon Snow is interesting here to bring
him up and back again because when the
books stopped that's when Jon Snow was
resurrected so anything after that
that's all new terrain well actually
before he resurrected so I don't even
know if he does come back right yeah
that's a TV show
they made so there's a lot of
speculations to be happening with the
books what do you personally think the
Georgia I'm Martin would cook up what do
you think his brain would do that would
differ from the series I gotta wonder
just knowing like the how long he's
taking to do this is it doesn't it feel
like maybe he's what he's gonna cook up
is whatever they don't do on the show
and whatever the audience is kind of
like I wish they had ended it like this
and he's like funny you should say my
gut is saying that it's not gonna be so
focused on the White Walkers in the
books because currently they're known as
the others there's far more mystery
around the others in the books then we
don't there's no night there's the
night's king which is a completely
different character in the books but the
night king as we saw him at hardhome and
as we learned about his origin in season
six and as he's targeted John at the
frozen ice lake in season seven that all
that is an invention of the show now
George or Martin has been a consultant
and a producer on the show but he's not
like sitting there writing scripts I
don't think he's breaking season stories
I mean Benioff and Weiss are checking in
with him but these this is really their
story from here on out and I have a
feeling the books are gonna be centered
more about the world at george RR martin
created there's more like a
fictionalized version of the dark
medieval history and basing things off
of how whole people really can be in
their pursuit of power i surprise
retched reading one particular scene
when Theon was north of the wall it was
like maggots in a body anyway it was
hard anyway uh-huh I think the biggest
difference between the show and the
books is obviously the books have like
90 times more characters and the TV show
has to sort of streamline it hence
combining two characters two and shaving
off big chunks of a side story so I
think he's going to kind of look at a
much bigger picture and use all of the
characters in said Game of Thrones so
it's a tricky one you're right it's not
as focused it's more about like the
socially Danny's story in the books I
mean you should have told the story
before now my focus is the show I love
reading a book before I have before I
see anything because I want to read it
and build my own mind around
I don't get to do that anymore yeah the
Marcin point you guys might sorry about
just like there there being just less
characters on the show I mean obviously
that's kind of we're talking about with
the Avengers earlier we're like that's
by design it's harder to tell a story in
that short time but I also do wonder if
that means that you know we've kind of
been tidying up the the battles of like
who's gonna win that Iron Throne and
it's been like well it's only like three
people left that I could maybe be and I
wonder if in the books it's actually be
like that's gonna be like the equivalent
of a world war like just all these
different you know sigils colliding
basically like that that's interesting
to me that he has room for so much more
politics
yeah and it's I am definitely gonna be
interested to see where he goes with
this I kind of think like in a show that
also has a very big following like lost
like a lot of people are upset with like
the last season where they had to wrap
up so much but it has two more two more
books you can really the kind of take
all the stories you have maybe
introduced like one or two more
mysteries but kind of just like wrap it
all up in a nice way while also paying
tribute to the characters that people
like from the books and but you just
didn't have a chance to introduce or
even he would never have a chance to
explore on the TV show so if he does it
it will be interesting know what though
i said george RR martin everything he's
gonna kill a dragon not just turn one
he's gonna kill another one yeah yeah
right the show might too but speaking of
game of thrones news in general remember
I said what's weeklies going back on
Monday okay so here's some details and
some stuff you guys are gonna find
interesting I feel like that would have
been perfect for a soundboard moment by
to buy but indeed it's gonna be hosted
by Maude is gonna come by and do some
fun stuff on it but this is kind of
what's important it's also gonna be a
podcast hopefully it'll be available for
you guys to you know drive home to and
ponder about what's just weekly is gonna
be the name of the entire audio feed for
all of our new rock stars Game of
Thrones coverage this is what I think
it's gonna be exciting for a lot of you
guys so it's gonna be Westeros weekly
the Q&A show on Monday afternoons but
we're also going to do on the podcast
the episode breakdowns that Eric is
gonna do just they're gonna show up
later in the week and then also we'll do
like some special bonus episodes every
what's wrong but that will also be on
the feed so our game Thrones coverage is
gonna be this part I feel like I always
have to say we're gonna do
two videos is gonna be the same thing
we're not gonna do any less YouTube
videos but what shows weekly and some
other Game of Thrones contents gonna
appear earlier on the podcast that's
what I think is really interesting for
you guys
so we know that you want our Game of
Thrones coverage as soon after Sunday
night as you can possibly get it and
since we're actually able to finish the
audio part a lot faster than the video
we actually are gonna be able to get you
the breakdown soon we've like never been
able to solve that problem getting you a
breakdown sooner but we realized we can
adjust the writing a little bit and they
get one closer eyes yeah exactly instead
of magic they can imagine the moon face
and then you guys will just get it
sooner on the podcast so that's a great
reason to go and subscribe to the
podcast if you just aren't gonna be able
to wait just keep in mind that the
content is not gonna be the same as the
feed that you're getting right now if
you listen to this podcast you need to
go separately and subscribe to the
Westeros weekly podcast and that's gonna
have Westeros weekly and the breakdowns
and anything else we do so you can go do
that right now the four of us are here
waiting yes
go ahead Alison yeah well we wait for
that let's talk about Zack Snyder first
like because he's like on a panel this
weekend went off on a rant that you've
all tweeted to me defending the choice
to have Batman kill people in Batman V
Superman and saying that people who
didn't believe Batman was the killer
we're living in an effing dreamworld
charming as a refresher Batman has
killed before in the Tim Burton Batman
movies and earlier Batman comics but he
has come to be known and accepted as a
character who does not kill people then
Zack Snyder came along and directed
Batman V Superman which comes out in
2016 and he runs over people with his
car and kills punch people in a
warehouse
they should have been bad people then
made this and they worked in the way
cover cops just needed a good defense
attorney well since this is back in the
news this week we thought we would weigh
in so I think we have two questions here
number one do you agree you and you with
Zack Snyder who seems to be saying that
if Batman / Bruce Wayne were real he
would kill people and number two do you
want to see the version of Batman that
kills or do you prefer the version of
Batman that is murder free kicking it
off let's go ahead and dive into it
first he's a fictional character so he
can do whatever he wants he can come up
with
every gadget doodad and whatnot in magic
pressure point that does not kill people
so no he does not need to murder people
if you want grounded movies about
fictional people in latex I don't know
there's a million of those who didn't go
get those somewhere else
what Sin City there you go the thing
about Batman is that he's an old shtick
is he likes to teach people a lesson how
is he gonna teach someone a lesson kills
them and don't have any gadgets like if
you're just gonna kill people just have
a gun yeah like don't worry about the
smoke bomb although the grappling hook
people a lot of different guns
I hear Zack Snyder's argument that like
yeah this guy existed he probably would
he's a psychopath to dress up as a padi
watch his parents die isn't super powers
though yeah but I think my the reason I
disagree with Snyder is like there is a
point to where this is a soul of the
character who he doesn't wanna kill
people but really for like there's a
structural reason it's more enjoyable
the fact that he doesn't kill the
rogue's gallery because that creates a
system where they go back and forth
round and round and round forever and if
he can just kill people then yeah but
what stop from just putting a bullet in
the head of the Joker in the pain gas in
a museum yeah right right the other one
yeah but like it's more fun if he
doesn't kill people yeah well I but but
I again I also I agree with so you had
two questions there the first question
would Batman be killing people if he was
real I think absolutely yes he totally
would by accident right like he does a
Turing with to serve yeah I mean like
battering of Flash and the you know how
many but people who weren't flashy
killed when he did that like Barry Allen
but really quick also he's not taking
into account any health hazards like in
a most recent run of daredevil daredevil
actually punching someone of the back of
the head they have an aneurysm because
they had a blood clot and they die they
die and that there's no way there's no
mechanism or back computer that could
measure give it a couple years they're
injured so bad they can't they walk with
like kind of a limp and what kind of
quality life are we talking in there so
I think that even though I said that he
would totally do it
I do commit to by accident because of
what you
glass over for a second but his his
thing that was the thing that broke him
was watching his parents die in front of
him to him death is like the the worst
thing that you can do if he's the Dark
Knight is trying to bring justice to
Gotham then he doesn't consider death
justice right he thinks that that is the
ultimate injustice but also another
flipside could be for him killing people
is that he is supposed to strike fear
into people's hearts and he doesn't want
to create any more orphans and and so in
his head that's all only he's saving all
the good boys and girls who might lose
their parents from criminals and not
thinking about the children of these
criminals that they're killing because
they they made the decision to be
criminals in the ferment kids the
criminals yeah how many kids are also
also how's the death penalty working out
as a deterrent against it I just mean
like the turn of like some bad is gonna
show up and kill me I'm probably good
but also what I would like no it's a
fictional character you can do whatever
you want Grant Morrison one of the
greatest writers in comic book history
and one of the best Batman writers wrote
it's just like adults seem to disconnect
with the point of these stories that
even children understand is that they're
fiction so they're allowed to do
whatever they want they can be anything
what they want they could be in other
universes other dimensions and they can
visit any character they want Superman
Batman can't exist in one place because
it is fiction so you say don't apply
logic to things you can apply enough
that we can still enjoy age in the first
place - it's called Batman but we need
to move on to another yeah just real
quick up before we actually move on I
want to give a quick thank you to
audible for sponsoring this video
audible has that insane selection of
audio books including Game of Thrones
the last season is coming up but if you
haven't read the books yet it's actually
a great way for you to discover a lot
more of those details like now in Game
of Thrones in the books I actually
personally used audible to listen to all
of the audiobooks myself they're
narrated by this really great British
actor Roy dotrice and he does the way
better voices than I do
almost Eric level voices they but
honestly like like some of them are like
the definitive version of these
characters for me and in general the
audiobooks are just a great way to learn
about anything while you're at the gym
or in a waiting room for waiting for
your child to be born or you know
cleaning just like some of you guys
actually right now are listening to this
episode you guys obviously would love
audible so you can get started with a 30
day trial when you go to audible.com
slash rockstars
and it's audible.com slash rockstars AUD
ible dot-com slash do you guys know
about rock stars ROC KST ARS great you
can also text the word rockstars to five
hundred five hundred if you prefer cuz
you know kids be texting I'm listening
to book ten of The Dresden Files
currently oh yeah
I also just I mean I did Game of Thrones
for audible but ever since then like you
get credits all the time so I've just
saw every book I'm ever curious about I
just like kind of buy it on audible
which they give you every month yes yeah
that's great well in other news some
other headlines that we saw this week
Game of Thrones will actually air a
two-hour documentary after the finale
it's gonna be called game of Thrones the
last watch and it will go behind the
scenes for make the making of the final
season so that's exciting yeah and we
also learned this week and other Game of
Thrones news that the prequel series
cast five new actors this week that's
one that has know me what's in it it's
taking we don't we're not sure if that
is the story of Valyria but they're
moving ahead in it so we'll have
something else to talk about that's
faster than we think because anytime
they're announcing casting they're
actually not announcing that they are
already in production most likely yeah
what if that documentary is actually
just a placeholder for the news also we
talked about this earlier but avengers
endgame runtime is confirmed as one
hundred and eighty two minutes it's
three hours and two minutes the longest
MCU runtime yet also the longest movie
ever ever made yeah so yeah there's
gonna be a lot of movie for us to sit
through use the bathroom before don't
get big drinks and other news this
excited me guys a Verna her song I knew
you would have a version of Werner
Herzog
in Star Wars series the Mandalorian he's
gonna be the bad guy this guy's awesome
he has like my favorite Parks and Rec
cameo ever his voice sounds so
villainous about striking fear in my
heart
in other news Apple announced a new
streaming service called Apple TV plus
it's gonna be featuring a reboot of
Spielberg's amazing stories like a up on
some of those in there they are like
almost like Twilight Zone or black mare
but softer and like kind of like more
like something more uplifting yeah a
little more Sanjana pero yeah yeah and
they have a bunch of other scripted and
unscripted content it's gonna launch in
May so it's it's right around the corner
and regarding the New Mutants remember
that Maisie Williams Arya Stark who is
it stars in this movie said quote who
knows when the F that's gonna come out
she sets herself she didn't but we did
hear okay I was surprised you didn't
have an aria impression I'm terrible I
can't do them all I'm not the man I'm
not Michael Winslow let us know if
you're disappointed in Erik in the
comments they don't need your direction
oh they're gonna be on prompter feed
them at us and we got answer all right
so you guys tweeted these questions you
guys we're gonna have them up on the
screen here and I'm gonna fire them on
my co-host who are gonna answer them as
quickly and without hesitation as
possible are we ready yes assemble at
Zeki wacky okay so I'm just gonna pick
who these are for yeah okay sure
okay at mod at Zeki wacky 69 what's the
nerdiest pick-up line just don't do it
boom just don't do it Sam
at kko 7 4 if Deadpool got dusted would
he still come back to life you know cuz
of his powers probably but it won't be a
good time for him Oh slowly does coming
back together Eric at GD shovel 14 isn't
Captain America just John Cena with a
shield for me F MK Thanos dr. evil or
gregor clegane have to married dr. evil
cuz he's got 1 million dollars I have to
kill thanos cuz he did everybody wrong
and he's also slightly thicker than me
and I want to be the thickest I mean
yeah you climbed burger like a mountain
yeah I like that
let's say
Sam at not Alexandra if you could pick
one character from any of the Marvel TV
shows to join The Avengers who would it
be
okay Luke 8 no it was one at Martin Pitt
how does becoming a wolf make Michael J
Fox better at basketball older fans
missed it I think
wolves can jump they're more agile and
ferocious and they never give up become
a wolf becomes a werewolf skywalker 27
this one's for sam basher who would win
in a footrace fat Barry Allen or just
Wilson Fisk no he got a lot of Barry
Allen cuz he's got that quick metabolism
all right for me at saucy Verdana Vader
vs. Johnson
snow no force abilities and both get
lightsabers who wins I think Jon Snow
immediately accidentally kills himself
when he activates the lightsaber second
is mr. boss if you found out that your
friends let's say they are at San
bachelor at fimo and that mod Garrett
and they are had the secret identities
of a scroll a werewolf and a host from
West world who would have what trait
okay so Sam would have a werewolf why
because he just helped me out on making
mod would be a host of Westworld straily
and we have Australian accents now
okay so that would make Philip a host of
Westworld like and Philips also there
all right speaking of Phil above for me
at obi-wan Bologna in Episode two fo9
when itchy plays scratchy skeleton like
a xylophone it's the same rib twice in
succession yet he produces two clearly
different tones I mean what are we to
believe that this is some sort of magic
xylophone or something I appreciate that
this whole question is a reference but
it's because the first time he does
damage to and hollows out the rib the
second time it produces a different tone
at Madh backwater Deb backwards Dan
backward AB what would be Sam's
nightmare cosplay to dress up as the
podcast what's up and let's say for all
of us wants a real quick at Jonesy 86
what is the most valuable piece of nerd
Merc you own
Sam you start oh I've done Vader's
lightsaber oh I got a firestorm figurine
and it's real pretty
what's up a Spider Man in Avengers
infinity war zip up one's a unitard I
have a recreation of ice the sword from
Game of Thrones
did you recreate it yeah and when they
melted it down to make team oh you're
like well now comes the time for a
15-second shout out where each of us is
15 seconds to shout out plug ramble
about anything we want
what's our 15 seconds shout out sound
effect
[Music]
another reference to a time gone by okay
next week if you tune in Tuesday to my
Twitter account at Sam basher I've been
working on a project for the past like
six six months and my brains been
melting and I really want to show it to
you so Tuesday you will know what it is
so please watch it and then subscribe to
what it is thank you Oh surprises Friday
April 5th I'll be joined by these three
wonderful people and several other funny
nerds in Los Angeles for the April
edition of darkest timeline comedy at
the Acme theatre in North Hollywood it's
gonna be super fun it's gonna be kind of
like a weird birthday show a real vanity
project but take a hit info birthday
yeah just everyone's birthday yeah but
yeah we'll see there it's gonna be a lot
of fun yeah my China I'm gonna do - uh
first off it's quick I'll just say pen15
it's so good it's my favorite thing ever
- shout-out to IMDB when you go on there
and see we can get Eric Foss credited as
just on on any project I don't think it
needs to be a Marvel project I think
everything you can get Erik Bosse credit
on let us know what it is cannonball run
- I've been doing this show for nearly
two years now and this is the first time
I've ever brought up that I have a
patreon so I figured over at my time as
patreon.com forward slash geek bomb the
patreon funds that we have is the only
reason why geek bomb is still up and
running I don't put it in my pocket I
literally put it back into the company
and pay my contributors and I pay my
contributors better than a lot of
companies in LA so you know I'm
supporting good good good good things
Sam basher and I have a SModcast coming
out season two and until we hit the
patreon goal which we are 90% for we'll
upload that new season when we hit that
so we're so close - big bomb very cool
all right guys I think it's time to
almost wrap up but we got to get to that
trivia answer to find out who dies today
all right so that question one more time
was early in their career
this MCU ster played a minor role in the
popular crime drama series chips all
right my answer but got marred over here
with Mickey Rourke and also you drew
Mickey Mouse which I feel like it's to
answer
so she should be disqualified done me
yeah [ __ ] pants on today great thank
you they are too tight Philip says
Benicio del Toro like my guess Benicio
del Toro Sam says Lou Ferrigno or Finn
Jones which wasn't born in early infant
baby riding on the back Oh Eric reckons
it's mu little Jackson we're also wrong
I'm Michelle Pfeiffer oh yeah hmm some
people described thin Jones's and
Michelle Pfeiffer I wanna I want to call
out my my my [ __ ] like thought for a
second and realize that we all assumed
that the California Highway Patrol could
only have men I'd rated I kept saying me
the whole time you should have
remembered that they accept all because
the California Highway Patrol is very
open also featuring demeaning female
characters in the late seventies
probably yeah I mean with a small role
in ships that probably wasn't a good one
was that a new movie which was mainly
men yeah we just played ourselves is
what I mean all right off screen
producer you want to help figure out
who's the most like Michelle Pfeiffer I
will say like honestly taking my stuff
out of it for a second Finn Jones he's
got features man like it seems to it's
pretty wasn't Mickey Rourke had a
similar hair to Michelle Pfeiffer
yeah I guess lately Mickey Rourke does
alright so that's my
who'sa furthest lou ferrigno orphan
jones so which again to answers Benicio
del Toro Jackson they're saying that the
everyone else was of a similar
generation and Finn Jones is just a dumb
answer to play stand up and do get the
same Finn Jones heads out there go ahead
and support me in the comments cuz this
is some BS supported a comment in Jones
fans and vision fans together the both
for each other I'm attacked this is
again BS put into my stamp on it to your
right snakes snakes there's one around
your wrists and neck to do the goodbye
Jones fan over here would alright and if
you're listening to us on the podcast
check us out on Twitter at new rock
stars to see this gif of shame in action
as always get to the Gipper shame mmm
goodbye since you also won I mean Finn
Jones is the real winner here I could do
it thank you thank you for watching and
listening to this the new rock stars I
just want to thank me I've got dragons
on my dress so I wanted that hell
and then also we've got a memo but I do
want to say this says that my twitter
handles I had sus sassy mama in LA black
suits guests I mean I wish I had that
Twitter handle it was taken so that
primo sassy mama
and yeah reminded that this episode is
in audio and video form you can find us
on video at new rock Swisscom Slatter
youtube.com slash new rock stars in
domain go daddy's really gonna stuff the
hill on it and you can find the audio
anywhere you get your podcasts but we'd
really love use the himalaya app you can
actually leave comments on the podcasts
and it will support the show directly if
you do that what are you doing and like
this video or podcast share it around
subscribe to new rock stars for deep
dives and all the stuff you love see you
next week guys fight
[Music]